-And finally,
have you guys noticed that
when you start typing something
on Google,
it automatically tries to
complete the search for you?
It autofills
what you're looking for.
Sometimes their suggestions
are a little off.
I'm gonna show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Google Autofails."
Here, check this out.
-♪ Google Autofails, yeah ♪
Here's an example
that I typed in.
I said,
"Which country should I..."
These three things pop up.
"...visit for Spring Break?"
"...check out in Europe?"
"...move to after the U.S.
bans TikTok?"
[ Laughter ]
These are autofills.
-Autofails!
Here's another one.
I typed in,
"Why did Tucker Carlson..."
It said,
"...get his own show?"
"...get the January 6th tapes?"
"...describe 'Creed III'
as 'mostly peaceful'?"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, I typed in,
"Are the contestants on
'The Masked Singer"..."
It said, "...really singing?"
"...getting paid?"
"volunteers or prisoners?"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, I typed in,
"Can H&R Block..."
It said, "...do my taxes?"
"...answer my questions?"
"...take a shoebox full
of loose documents
and make sure I don't
go to prison?"
[ Laughter ]
"Look at this. Help me."
And finally, I typed in,
"I feel out of control when..."
It said, "...I party too much."
"...I have too much work."
"...the steering wheel
on my Tesla falls off."
That's it for
"Google Autofails"!